>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mike Ashenfelder: So
Kiersten White is the giver
of the world's most awkward hugs.
She's a New York Times
best-selling author of books such as
And I Darken, the Paranormalcy
series with Paranormalcy,
Supernaturally and Endlessly, Mind
Games, Perfect Lies, Annie and Fia,
The Chaos of Stars,
Illusions of Fate.
She writes thrillers from
a young adult point of view
about princesses, extraordinary
girls with extraordinary powers,
girls that find their strength in
bravery to confront weird challenges
such as fairies and
werewolves and vampires
and other bits of supernatural
stuff.
I just finished reading Paranormalcy
and I have two teenage daughters
and I can really see Evie in them.
Kiersten really gets the
tone of -she get their tone.
So I imagine my daughters
having Evie's flipping attitude
around really scary
characters and pulling
out [inaudible] and doing damage.
So please welcome Kiersten White.
[ Applause ]
>> Kiersten White: Well thank
you for reading Paranormalcy.
You are actually my
exact target audience.
[ Laughter ]
I've been surprised at how
many teen girls read the books,
but that's all right.
Thank you so much for coming.
I am aware that Raina Telgemeier
is speaking at the same time
so I appreciate you being here.
I would probably go watch her too.
[ Laughter ]
So thank you.
So I'm Kiersten White.
It's always interesting hearing
yourself introduced by someone else.
How do I get the PowerPoint started?
It's really bright up here you guys.
Just -which one?
I'm so excited to be
here with you today.
This is my first National
Book Festival and so I feel
like it's a really big honor
and privilege to be here.
My most recent book is And I
Darken; it's epic historical fiction
about a gender-swapped
Vlad the Impaler.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about why I decided to write
about historical fiction and
more specifically why I decided
to write an antiheroine.
But as I was planning this
-usually when you do events
or festivals you're on a panel
with several other authors
and people ask you questions
and you answer, so when I found
out that I just had thirty minutes
on a stage by myself here...
[ Laughter ]
This was my original topic
and my publicist was like,
"Oh I need your PowerPoint
right now."
And I'm like, "I don't know."
So once I got past deciding to write
a PowerPoint about PowerPoints,
I thought about trying to guess what
audiences will find interesting;
it depends, it varies
from audience to audience.
I thought about writing
about historical fiction.
If any of you are aspiring writers,
I have a huge writing tip for you;
don't write historical fiction.
You guys, it's so hard.
One time I did five
hours of research
on traditional Arabic erotic poetry
conventions -did I lose the mic
or is it just less [inaudible]?
OK, good. And those five hours
of research informed
two lines in the book.
And I guarantee you people aren't
going to read those and be like,
"she's a really bad poet."
[ Laughter ]
The existential crisis
of writing period.
Writing is super fun and I'm
really privileged to be able
to do it professionally, but
sometimes we feel like Leo
over there, although
he has better hair.
But I finally settled on talking
about the peculiar morality
of villains; is my actual topic.
And it's something that
I struggled with deciding
to write an antiheroine who
is essentially a villain.
And it became a little bit more
of a struggle as I saw in the U.K.
when they we're promoting
the book kept talking
about Lada is a new feminist
icon, and I was like,
"You do realize she's
an antiheroine?"
But that's all right, girls
are allowed to be bad too.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm going to tell you a little
bit about Vlad the Impaler.
Generally in an audience I can pick
out exactly who is going to know
who Vlad the Impaler was.
You guys are really obvious, yes.
I once had a guy at [inaudible]
come up and I'll say like,
"Do you know who Vlad
the Impaler is?"
And most people will be like, "No."
And this guy had a
handmade chain mail bracelet
and like dragon cross earrings
and I looked at him and I said,
"I'm not even going to ask if you
know who Vlad the Impaler was."
And he's like, "Oh yeah I do."
[ Laughter ]
So Vlad the Impaler was obscure
Romanian price in the 1400s,
and his last name was actually
Dracul which if that's familiar is
because Bram Stoker used him
as the inspiration for Dracula.
He was that notoriously not nice.
So Vlad grew up as a political
prisoner in the Ottoman courts
as the same time as Mehmed the
conqueror who was the Ottoman Sultan
who at the age of twenty-one would
go on to overthrow Constantinople
which was something that people
had been trying to do for centuries
and had never been able to, but
he was so brilliant and driven
that he was the one who did it.
And Vlad and his brother Radu,
who had the much kinder
historical nomenclature
of Radu the Handsome, right?
Sometimes I wonder what
I want to be known as
and I think it'll be
Kiersten the Napper.
[ Laughter ]
So Vlad and Radu grew up and it
was not an easy way to grow up;
they were educated, they
were expected to become part
of the Ottoman Empire, but they
experienced a lot of cruelty.
It's history, people weren't nice.
And when they grew up the Ottomans
actually put Vlad on the throne
of Romania as their prince, but it
was sort of a puppet prince thing,
it was the understanding of you
are going to serve our interests.
Whereas, Radu stayed with the
Ottomans and he stayed loyal
and he converted to Islam and
he never went back on that
for the rest of his life.
But Vlad was not a
fan of the Ottomans,
and he was deeply,
deeply nationalistic.
So he went on to antagonize
them in every way that he could.
There's one letter from him -so
the other European allies asked
[inaudible] don't make
the Ottomans mad.
Let's just keep things
at a base level.
Let's keep things friendly
because you didn't want
to make Mehmed the Conqueror mad
because he was Mehmed the Conqueror.
And Vlad once wrote a letter
saying, "I went into Bulgaria
and I slaughtered tens of thousands
of people and we killed them
in their homes and we killed them
in their street, and so, yes,
I think I might have
broken the treaty."
Like a little bit, just
a little bit he broke it.
And so what he did was he was so
determined to have his own country
that he was going to do
whatever it took to keep it.
And the thing you got
to remember though is
at the time the Ottomans were
kind of the guys you wanted to be
because they had religious
tolerance,
they didn't are whether
or not you were Muslim.
Actually they preferred you didn't
convert because they could tax you
at a higher rate if
you were Christian.
But they didn't kill
you for not converting.
They didn't believe in feudalism
so everyone had opportunities
for advancement.
When Mehmed overthrew
Constantinople,
he opened the city up, he
invited Jewish refugees
from Spain from the Inquisition.
And he really wanted to have
this sort of European jewel.
He wanted the brightest minds,
he wanted the best people
and he didn't care
where they came from.
So they were actually really good
people to have over your country;
I mean, yes, they asked for
taxes and they asked for boys
for their army, but
that was about it
and Vlad refused, he
refused to do that.
And so what he did was when he knew
the Ottomans were coming he engaged
in all out scorched earth warfare.
He diverted rivers to make
his own land into marshes.
He burned his crops.
He poisoned his wells.
He found anybody that was sick
in his people and he sent them
into the Ottoman camps
to circulate and try
to get them sick, so
he had germ warfare.
And he did all of these things.
He even used his own intimate
knowledge of their practices
to dress in their uniforms
and sneak into their camp
and launch a night attack
which actually might have worked
had his own people supported him,
but they didn't.
So finally Mehmed and his army
get through this just nightmare
that Vlad has created for them
and they get to the capital city,
and lining the road to the capital
that has its gates open are ten
or twenty thousand
impaled Turkish soldiers.
So it was quite the greeting.
And at this point the
Turkish army said,
"We don't know what
to do with this."
So they turned around and they left.
He actually won, except he had made
so many people angry and had damaged
so much of his own land that his
own people no longer supported him.
So you're probably thinking here's
a nice German woodcut of him eating
in the middle of a
forest of impaled bodies.
This is a portrait of him.
So I know that you guys are
looking at him, you're knowing all
that history and you're
saying, "teenage girl" right?
Maybe not.
But I knew all this history and I
thought it was really interesting.
I had actually travelled to
Romania in 2010 and my husband
and I visited almost all of
his historical sites just kind
of on the side because we
were going to Romania anyway.
And as my husband was
telling my mom about all
of this history I was thinking
about it and thinking about it
and thinking how does
somebody to that point?
How does someone get to the point
where they can justify
committing atrocities
in the name of their own goal?
Like how does that happen?
Because it has to be gradual.
And then I thought, "But
what if he had been a girl?"
And you know for most authors
that's how books start,
it's that whole what if.
And for me him being a girl
just made so much more sense
because as a girl you have to work
harder, you have to be smarter,
you have to be better at everything
to attain just the same base level
as other people get for being boys.
And so once I turned Vlad into
Lada suddenly that ruthlessness
and that willingness to do anything
to meet her goals made a lot
of sense to me as a story teller.
So some of the things that I
wanted to explore -guys I was
so unambitious with this book.
I wanted to explore gender,
I wanted to explore politics,
queer [phonetic] identity, faith.
All of those things that
I loved writing in history
because you can kind of detach
them from our modern sensibilities,
you don't have to address
them in context of our culture
and what's going on today and
you can really explore them
as the concepts that they are
rather than our particular culture.
One thing that I really tried hard
in this book was to capture faith.
One of the characters converts
to Islam and it's a very healing
and very powerful thing in his life
and that was really important to me
as a person of faith to try
and capture that in a YA book.
But mostly I wanted to
ask that central question
and that central question is how,
how do people, normal people,
get to the point where they
can allow and commit atrocities
and do these terrible things.
You guys, this is such
a cheerful topic.
[ Laughter ]
You can imagine how pleasant I
am when I'm writing these books.
I'm sitting there in
Starbucks and everybody
around me -yeah you guys,
its historical fiction.
And I really don't think that
these anti-heroine stories are
about the shock factor.
For me it's not about the darkness
or the violence or anything,
it's really looking at how -because
we experience history as a story,
it's already been packaged
for us and most
of the time it's been packaged
for us by the people who wrote it.
So for example, when I was
researching Mehmed the Conqueror,
all of the European
accounts of him were like,
"He was drunk all the time and
he was this terrible person
and he committed all
these atrocities."
And I'm going, "If that guy was
drunk all the time I don't think he
would of been able to
overthrow an entire city
by the age of twenty-one.
He was actually brilliant,
but when you read about him
from his enemies you get a very
different picture than when you read
about him from the people who
loved him and who knew him.
And so what I tried to do is
I tried to read both extremes
and then find a middle path.
It's a little bit like
Fox News versus -you got
to find that middle path.
And so trying to find
that and trying
to find the real people among
the history was the challenge
because so often we
look at these things
and we say, "Yes, that was bad."
We can agree that is was bad.
The end result was bad,
but when we only focus
on the end result we fail
to see how it happened.
And you look at Vlad the
Impaler and he was so deeply,
deeply nationalistic, it
was his country or nothing,
and he actually ended up
destroying his own land,
killing a lot of his own people,
and in the end losing the throne
to a foreign power anyway.
And so that to me is the
value of the antihero story
of tracing these paths; it's
not to look at the darkness,
but to look at how you get
there and to really explore
that so we don't forget that
these things happen in cycles
and they happen over and over again.
And so that value and that strength
of knowing those stories can
help us realize in our own lives,
as a nation, as a world
like where are we getting
to the point where
we've tipped over.
So really light, fun,
happy writing you guys.
So I do. I feel like there's value
in the telling beyond entertainment
because the stories that
we tell and the stories
that we love become part of us.
And if we tell the important stories
whether they're happening now
or whether they're happening in
the 1400s in the Ottoman Empire,
reliving to stories and
revisiting them will help us
to create our own lives in
the ways we want them to be.
So no pressure just like no
pressure when you're speaking
at the National Book
Festival, right?
[ Laughter ]
So I talk really fast.
That is the end of my presentation.
I am open to questions.
You can ask me about writing.
You can ask me about history.
You can ask me about math,
but I guarantee you you're
in the wrong audience for that one.
So does anybody have any questions
that they would like to ask?
>> Hi. Thanks.
I'll go first.
I was curious if you could talk
about your writing process?
Because I find that one of the
success with all of your books is
that you do everything right.
>> Kiersten White: Well thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> The [inaudible] is magical.
>> Kiersten White: Thank you.
>> The plot, the characterization,
and the details
like thread throughout it.
>> Kiersten White: I'm not
actually related to her you guys.
[ Laughter ]
>> Your first draft
[inaudible] into the end result.
What comes easy to you in all
those elements of writing?
And then what do you add later
further on in your later drafts?
>> Kiersten White: I think
everybody has their strengths
and weaknesses in writing.
I'm a fairly strong drafter
so by the time I actually sit
down to draft I write very
complete very clean drafts.
But one of my strengths
is writing dialogue,
I love writing dialogue,
I think it's really fun.
I would write entire books
of dialogue if I could,
but then my editors are like.
"Where are they?"
And I'm like, "I don't
know, they're in a room."
"Like what does the room look like?"
I'm like, "I don't know,
they're just talking."
And so for me a lot of that detail
work is when I have to go back in
and really fill in and work
on what are they wearing?
Where are they?
What do they look like?
Another hint; if you
don't like description,
if you don't like describing
landscapes or rooms or food,
don't write historical fiction
you guys, it's so much work.
So this one was definitely
a challenge to me
in that I did not play to my
strengths and so I really had
to buckle down and figure out like
how do I incorporate that sense
of place because it's
historical fiction and so you need
to feel grounded because I can't
just say they were in a small town
in Virginia, and we all
have a general sense of what
that feels like, but I can't
say they were in the small town
of [inaudible], you guys
don't know where that is
and what that feels like.
And so I really had to
kind of dig in deeper
and do the detail work on this one.
So really every book has different
challenges; some of them are harder
to piece together the
timeline, some of them I have
to work more on detail work.
So my process generally
I start with a question.
I was actually talking last
night with some authors
about what you start with and some
of them start with a character
and some of them start with an idea.
And for me generally I start
with a question, it's what I want
to explore with the book.
For me the plot comes in
relation to that question.
So Paranormalcy I wanted to see can
I write a funny paranormal romance?
Because that was back in the day
of Twilight when no one noticed
that if your vampire
boyfriend sparkles
in the sun that's hilarious.
Like you guys, that's really funny.
I would hang him on
my rear-view mirror.
[ Laughter ]
And the questions vary; And I
Darken it was how do good people get
to the point where they
can justify atrocities?
That was super fun.
I have a middle grade
book coming out next year
where my question was can I
write a ten page long pee joke?
And the answer is yes.
So yeah, I have to have that
drive because if I don't have
that question that
I'm trying to answer
as the writer then I lose
interest in the book.
And I have a lot of fifty,
sixty, seventy page starts
that I never go anywhere
with because
that central question
wasn't there for me.
So writing process is a hard thing
to talk about because it's different
for everyone, but for me I
just have to have that soul,
that core of the book that I'm
engaged in and I'm exploring
and I think everything
else comes after that.
Does anyone else have a question
that I can vaguely not answer?
[ Laughter ]
Yes? Oh hi.
This is Jon Skovron, young adult
and adult writer, most recently Hope
and Red which is a
fantastic fantasy.
>> Jon Skovron: Thanks Kiersten.
>> Kiersten White: You're welcome.
>> Jon Skovron: I actually have a
historical fiction question for you;
how do you balance
the needs of the story
with the actual historical
events and details?
>> Kiersten White:
That's a good question.
And it's even more difficult in YA
because YA the emphasis
is on movement.
I feel like adult writing
you can get a little bit more
self-indulgent, really sink
down into the description,
but YA we're known for the stories
move quickly and there's a lot
of action and engagement.
So that was a really big
problem with book two
because I did all this research
you guys, so much research,
thousands of pages of research, so
much on the fall of Constantinople.
And so I knew all of these
details and these amazing anecdotes
and these actual historical figures
and I wanted to include all of them
because I put in the time
to learn about all of them
and gosh darn it I
wanted them on the page.
But my editor, who is very wise,
pointed out like these two men
served the exact same function.
And I'm like, "But they were
actual historical figures,
they were both there."
But as far as the narrative
was concerned,
they really only filled one role so
there only needed to be one of them.
I actually had notes that
said get rid of Lucas,
and I have a nephew named
Lucas and my mom saw that paper
and she was like, "What
are you talking about?"
I'm like, "Not him.
Not him. He's cute,
we can keep him."
So I feel like you have to give
them just enough to have a sense
of the history and a sense
of the place and to feel
like they're learning
things, but not so much
that it reads like a history text.
But the greatest thing that I hear
after people read the book is,
"then I went on like a Wikipedia
rabbit hole researching what
actually happened with
all of these characters."
Because you do want to have as much
truth to the history as you can,
but in the end you're telling
a story and history is messy
and it doesn't have those nice
through lines with the story.
So like in book two I also
have the Hungarian court
and I actually have a note in the
back where I apologize to Hungary
as a country entirely because
of what I did to their history.
I'm so sorry Hungary.
But I couldn't get into it because
it was too big and too complicated.
So for historical fiction, I
think trying to get a feel for it
and a sense for it without getting
so bogged down on the actual history
that it reads like a
textbook, it's hard.
Again, don't make historical
fiction you guys, it's so hard.
Do you have any other questions?
Yes?
>> Since you found it so hard
to write a historical fiction
about Vlad the Impaler, did
you ever think of changing it
to strictly fiction and keep him
gender bent and do Vlad the Impaler
as a vampire because
it would be easier?
>> Kiersten White: It
would have been easier.
No because the interest for me with
this project was the actual history
because I think you
can't get better stories
that history already
offers you; more dynamic
or incredible people
doing astonishing things.
So I really did definitely want
to include the actual history
and it was important to
me not to -my only problem
with this book is are no vampires.
And because that's all
people know of the history
and Romania has a special place in
my heart and I really wanted to kind
of introduce that to a lot of people
who wouldn't have any idea about it,
although I do get Romanians that
are super excited and Romanians
who are like, "This
is not our history.
He was a boy."
I'm like, "I know, I'm sorry.
I just really wanted
him to be a girl."
I don't know that I would do
straight historical fiction again.
I probably would do historical
influenced fantasy so that instead
of doing five hours of research
to find our whether a house
in the Moldovan countryside
would have windows
that opened -no one has
written about that you guys.
No graduate students have ever
written a research paper on windows
in the fifteenth century in
the countryside of Moldova,
although you'd be amazed
at what graduate students
have done papers on.
Thank you graduate students of the
world who post your paper online.
[ Laughter ]
Instead of having to do five
hours of research and then end
up just writing the
window out of the scene,
you could say it opens
because of magic.
[ Laughter ]
Right? You can't do that
in historical fiction.
One of the reasons why I gender
swapped Vlad the Impaler was so that
if people were like, "That's
not how things happened."
I'm like, "Well he wasn't a girl
so we already changed history
so that's how it happens now."
[ Laughter ]
Yes?
>> I was wondering since you
mentioned some of the hardships
and difficulties you encounter
when writing, what were some
of the things that you did
to keep you motivated
during your writing process?
>> Kiersten White: I sold a
book before it was finished.
[ Laughter ]
So I was contractually obligated.
No, but I understand
writing is hard.
And you have an idea that you
love and you get started on it
and you get so fired up about it
and then you get to the middle
and you're like, "Oh, I
actually have to fix all
of the problems that I set up."
And it's a lot easier to
just jump to something new.
One thing that I try
to do is a try to set
up a really regular
drafting schedule for myself
like right now I have a calendar
for the next three months
and I have listed the amount that
I have to write every single day
and I find that motivation
really helps me.
Another thing that I do is at
the end of the day when I'm done
with my writing, I
take just a few minutes
and I write just a few
sentences on the next page
about what happens next
so the next time I sit
down to write I'm not staring at a
blank page, that infinite whiteness
that I have to fill up, it already
has words there telling me Kiersten
this is what you're doing today.
So that for me really helped.
And also it was a story that was
important to me and it was one
that I really wanted to tell.
So even though it was hard -guys
I just started writing book three.
Oh my gosh.
Even though it was hard,
it was important to me
and it was important
to tell it well.
So I really wanted that challenge
and wanted to stretch as a writer
so that I could create the best
version of this story that I could.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Kiersten White: Thank you.
Yes?
>> [Inaudible].
>> Kiersten White: That's all right.
You are in good company.
>> I have two questions.
My first question is
from the variety
of languages taught toward
Lada, Radu, [inaudible]
and Mehmed are you
possibly fluent in one
of the languages spoken
within the book?
>> Kiersten White: Oh I wish.
I actually only speak English
and a little bit of Spanish,
but my husband, you
guys I married so well,
besides being good looking he
is fluent in Romanian and Arabic
and he's currently learning Greek
because being trilingual
is boring, right?
The only thing he doesn't
speak is Turkish
and I was really annoyed
with him for that.
He should have learned
Turkish to benefit me.
>> I actually know a little Turkish.
>> Kiersten White: Yeah?
>> Yeah I do.
>> Kiersten White: Well
I could have used you.
[ Laughter ]
And one thing that I chose to do
in this book is a lot of times
in books you'll see words in
foreign languages italicized,
but because this is taking place
in an area of the world and a time
in the world where they had to
know several languages in order
to survive and everything
would have been familiar.
I choose not to italicize
anything because I didn't want
to make any other languages look
like another language, so yeah.
>> My second question was
which character would you say you
could have most related to and why?
>> Kiersten White:
That's a good question.
So people have asked if I'm
a not like Lada and I'm like,
"Are you afraid of me
if you think that I am?"
She's not really nice you
guys, she's quite violent.
But actually the character
that I personally relate
to the most is Radu; he's more
sensitive, he's very emotional,
he is deeply committed to
the people that he loves
and he's a little bit sly
and sneaky and cunning.
And somebody was like, "Oh
Radu is such a Hufflepuff."
I'm like, "Oh sweetheart,
Radu is a Slytherin."
[ Laughter ]
One hundred percent.
So yeah, I think he's the character
that I actually relate to the most
and the things that he goes
through, particularly his conversion
and his relationship to faith was
very personal for me to write.
>> Hi. What happened in Hungary
that you needed to apologize for?
>> Kiersten White:
[ Laughter ]
>> Kiersten White: So every country
has their own amazing intricate
history and there was a Hungarian
leader named John Hunyadi
who was this amazing military leader
who was also contemporary of Mehmed
and Vlad the Impaler, and he
actually at one point took Vlad in
and trained him and was
sort of an ally to him.
And there's all sort of drama
that went on in that time period;
Hunyadi's son Matthias who actually
had no claim to the throne ended
up working his way in to be King
of Hungary and then he had to wait
and get money to try and buy
back his crown from Poland
because Poland likes to
take other people's crowns
and not give them back.
And so it was all these things that
happened over the course of a couple
of decades, but for the purpose
of my narrative I just needed John
and Matthias to get their
act together and to get
that throne a lot faster
and to need Lada to do it.
So I basically just
skimmed through decades
of history and ignored most of it.
So I'm sorry Hungary, you really
do have fantastic history.
All right.
We have five minutes left.
Do you know how many questions
I can answer in five minutes?
So many.
[ Laughter ]
Just kidding.
Yes? We're all so short in here.
I love it.
>> Yes. You've talked a little
bit about having to take things
out of the narrative that
you'd really like to include.
Is there something in this
book that you really wished
that you could have left
in or is there something
in your previous books that you
wished you could have left it?
>> Kiersten White:
That's a good question.
I think I end up feeling like
if I have to take something
out there's a reason to take it out.
So people will ask, "are
there deleted scene?"
Yeah, but if they're deleted
there's a reason for that.
My best example of that
was actually Paranormalcy,
which is my first book,
and I ended up cutting
about forty pages before
I sent it out to editors.
And one of the scenes was this
day when Evie goes to high school
and it was adorable and she got
to go to high school and she got
to make all of these jokes
relating it to teen dramas on TV
and it just kind of
went on and on and on
because I was having fun writing it
and I was having fun giving her all
of those experiences, but what
it did was it dragged the plot
to a standstill and it sucked all
of the narrative tension
out of the book.
And so my friend and critique
partner Stephanie Perkins,
who is brilliant, said, "This
doesn't need to be here."
And at first I was like,
"No, but I love it so much."
And then I realized OK it
doesn't need to be here.
And those things that I
loved so much about it
like that really good joke or this
fun scene I could actually pull
out and put in other places.
So out of the fifteen pages, there
were really only a few paragraphs
that I loved so much and I
used them somewhere else.
So for me the editorial process is
just as important as the drafting
because the drafting gets
the story on the paper.
I would say stories are
made in the first draft,
books are made in editing.
So I never get too attached and
often times I forget what I cut
because it's not essential
to the story.
>> [Inaudible].
>> Kiersten White:
And editors are great.
Editors are so smart you guys.
Editors are the best because
they can look at what you made
and say, "This is so good.
I love this so much.
Here's ten pages on
what you need to fix."
[ Laughter ]
And you're like, "OK."
But then they're right
on everything, so yeah.
I've had people ask if I
would ever self-publish
because I have several manuscripts
that I've written completely
and that didn't for whatever
reason get published and I say no
because I don't want to put out
anything that's not my absolute best
and I feel that editors make my
stuff [phonetic] my absolute best,
so it's important to
me to go through that.
Do you have any other questions?
Yes?
>> How did you get like Radu
and Lada -the book starts
when they're smaller and they grow
up, how did you make that so real?
Because for me it was
very well written.
>> Kiersten White:
Aw, thank you so much.
I really wanted to start from
-it starts when they're born
and I wanted to start that way so
you could really see everything
that went into informing
who they are.
I really like writing
sibling dynamics.
I actually have four siblings,
three sisters and a brother,
and then I always end up writing
really antagonistic really unhealthy
sibling relationships and they all
still like me so I guess I'm OK,
although when they were
reading one of my books all
of my sisters not knowing the other
ones had done it texted me and said,
"I'm kind of scared of you now."
And I was like, "You
knew me in high school,
you should have been scared
of me a long time ago."
But yeah, I really, really
love writing sibling dynamics
because I think that these are
people that we don't choose,
but that we're connected to
our entire lives and that's
such an interesting and fraught
and rewarding relationship,
so I really like writing those.
>> Hi.
>> Kiersten White: Hi.
>> I have two questions.
>> Kiersten White: OK.
>> My first is, and you
must get this a lot,
not every aspiring writer is
going to get their first book
and it's going to be really good.
What would you suggest,
like any tips,
if you wanted to become a
writer, but you're not sure?
>> Kiersten White: Yeah,
well my first book that came
out was not my first book,
it was my fourth book,
so that right there, you know?
It takes a while.
So my advice if you want
to be a writer is to read.
Read very widely, read what's
popular, read classics,
and look at it while you're
reading it, really pay attention.
If you can't put it down,
what is the author doing
that is engaging your
interest so much?
And if you get bored and
you're losing interest,
what has the author done
that has let you say, "Meh.
I don't really want to keep
reading this anymore."?
Because reading is
really the best education
in writing that you can get.
And then as far as
trying to get published,
it really is just a
matter of doing the work,
of sitting down finishing the draft,
editing it, getting it as best
as you can, and then sending it out
there and starting the next thing.
I actually started writing
Paranormalcy when another book
of mine was on submission to
editors, and nobody bought that.
It's not a really fun way to do it.
By the way, I really recommend
selling a book instead
of not selling a book,
its way more fun.
But in the meantime I had
been writing Paranormalcy,
so when it was very clear that
first book wasn't going to sell,
I had something else
and I had something else
to give my agent and to go out with.
And I didn't get an agent
right off the bat either,
it took fifty letters, inquiry
letters you write to an agent
and you say, "Hey, I wrote this
book, do you want to read it?"
And they write back and say no
or they don't write back at all.
So it took me fifty of
those to get an agent.
And then it took me my fourth book
to get published, so I say just keep
at it, that's really the best thing
you can do is just keep writing.
And we're actually out of
time, but keep writing, OK?
It's worth it.
And everything you
write you learn from,
there's no writing that's wasted.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you for choosing
me over Raina.
[Applause]
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.